Trent Dilfer returns to talk soul and
science with his partner in this new NFL
Network series that debuted on Wednesday
on NFL Total Access you saw it this
morning on Good Morning football John
Brenkus the co-founder and co-ceo of
bass productions and creator of sports
science is here as well cuz a six-time
Emmy Award with six Emmy Award winner
and the short one in this partnership
was the good-looking one I tend to be
the smarter okay you're the science John
sure and Trent you're clearly the soul
so he's is also look at him you're the
song that's s o UL
so where did this sense where the idea
came from but John how did this forget
born out here so Trent I had just one of
those you know when you meet somebody
you immediately click with them and for
many years we always saying look we're
looking at the same thing but from two
different lenses we would have good
spirited arguments about the science
side versus what we refer to as the soul
side there are tangibles and sports
there are intangibles and sport right so
sports science was a look at sport
through one lens soul and science is
really taking a more comprehensive look
it's a deeper dive into the world of
sport that we feel has never really been
done and you're using for the first
iteration of this all the top prospects
in this year's draft you got you got
them all Allen and Rosen darn 'old
Mayfield Lamar Jackson and Luke Falk
among others we analyzed all we analyzed
eight of the top quarterbacks and what
you find so what'd you find
well I think it can be a historic draft
I love this group I think it's very
diverse from how they play I think we
have different sizes we have different
athletic skill sets we have different
intangible skill sets yes I think
there's two that are ready to play right
away and Arnold and Rosen
I think he'll differ on one of them
right I think Allen josh Allen is a
unbelievable talent off-the-charts
talent I think it's still raw and
unhonest I think it needs to be what in
particular he grew up in a town of 7,500
he went to a juice small junior college
to a small school wasn't that Carson
Wentz - yeah but Carson Wentz is an
outlier just because it happened one
time doesn't mean it's gonna happen
every single year okay but bigger than
that I think that he just needs to be
introduced and brought along slowly of
something bigger than what he's been a
part of I think there is this he resorts
to this power under pressure and that's
where the completion percentage drops a
little bit he'll throw you a rocket for
me to you because that's what he's
always known Jerry give him time to grow
and to see the game through an NFL lens
and be coached by an NFL teacher every
day and see another guy do it and see
kind of the nuance of the game and you
could have something special there I
think that when you look at the metrics
for Josh Allen you have genuinely I can
say this he's arguably the strongest arm
ever in the history of the NFL are you
serious that he's blown away buyers are
testing on him well so his average
release velocity and all the tests that
we did was 72 plus miles per hour that's
complete and since it's so insane I'm
like that can't possibly be true when
he's feathering the ball over the second
line of defenders in an in a test that
we call firm with ARC he's still
throwing it 50 miles per hour he's
getting rid of the ball in terms of
release in separation 4/10 of a second
is the elite category you need to be in
for the NFL he's in point three eight
seconds
he throws great on the run he throws
great with pocket mobility resetting his
platform he's just he is a physical
specimen I can say unlike anything the
NFL has ever seen now that rawness yes
in that completion percentage he only
completed 56 percent of his passes it's
a very misleading stat Brett Favre only
completed 52% of his passes in college I
think that you have when you level it
and take away spikes and take away
intentional grounding it actually goes
up to 65 plus percent that those kind of
stats are very misleading
if I'm a GM and I'm sitting back I'm
saying I can't teach this kind of raw
talent if I draft him and put him on the
sidelines for a year year and a half
let him develop you have something that
no one else has ever had you know the
NFL lacks as much as anything right now
in the culture of the NFL the media then
FL on the coaches of the NFL discernment
and that's exactly what's gonna take to
make Josh Hollan great is discernment
what do you mean by that it's gonna take
a head a GM an owner a GM head coach
this says okay we know we're getting
something unbelievable here but we
cannot no matter what
throw him out there too soon no matter
how good it looks in practice no matter
how much the quarterback coach says he
gets it no matter how much it looks good
day in and day out we have to be
discerning enough to not be knee-jerk
and throw him out there too soon if we
can give this kid a year one year of
just sitting and watching and then maybe
even year two kind of baby step it now
you could have something special but the
NFL lacks that but at the top of the
draft Trent Dilfer and John Brenkus here
for NFL Network's Solon science you know
what you're going to say and my answer
is why you have to play things if you
look at the top of the draft though good
news for it Josh Allen and for
discernment is that everybody's got a
bridge quarterback everybody jets have
to they've cornered the market on a
bridge quarterbacks the Giants have I
feel bad it's a lie a bridge quarterback
when you draft somebody that high you
intend to start this individual sooner
rather than later
Tyrod Taylor and Cleveland Denver
deviling obviously Casey case keenum but
John you mentioned or the two of you
that there was a disagreement about the
top of the draft here basically and what
who do you think that might be separate
from what Trent thinks based on your so
I'm very very high on Josh Allen I just
heard that but right there I mean that
Trent wood would be much higher on Sam
Donaldson Gerald's great he's awesome
out of the box we we certainly blow away
the myth that he has this slow looping
release I don't even know where it
started somebody said it and then it
kept being perpetuated but he has a
quicker release than Derek Carr and even
Jameis Winston so he's walking into the
NFL ready I think that what's
interesting about this draft is I feel
it's very similar
to the 2012 draft in 2012 you had Andrew
Luck you had rg3 you had Russell Wilson
Kirk Cousins are cousins
you had Brock Osweiler you had Nick
Foles two of those guys have gone on to
win Super Bowls neither of which went in
the first round correct I think when you
look at you know we got Faulk we have
Mason Rudolph you have guys that are
flying under the radar
more than because just because this
class of quarterbacks is so special
think that we will look back 10 years
from now and say this was a really
special class of quarterbacks because
there are so many situations like you
pointed out where there is that bridge
quarterback where they don't have to
come in and be the savior but if they're
being asked to be the savior day one I
think it's tough for any rookie what is
Alan your top choice because of this
sports science at period just here are
the metrics the pure numbers and what
you are seeing from your sports science
knowledge yes to me Josh Alan is the on
paper on metrics that's that's the guy
that blew me away the most I think that
Trent is right though you can't start
him day one he definitely needs that
time to mature but he has something that
everybody else does in terms of pure
metrics is there anybody doubt that we
haven't even in the second hour or now
Trent mentioned quarterback prospects
that you think has the ability to be the
next Jimmy J the next guy that's taken
sir at second or third or fourth round
that I mentioned I mentioned Luke Falk
to the Patriots I think is a no-brainer
I think Mason were off there's
tremendous value there um he's very much
like Nick Foles he's they had the same
demeanor the same stature there's
nothing super flashy but it's just
really solid how about this kid lo Letta
that I keep hearing about the Richmond
spider yeah like why yeah there's some
fun stuff they're not there every year I
fell into this trap when I was doing the
draft for ESPN you end up you want that
story so you look more into it than
there really is
uh-huh they're definitely good players
and I think the bottom what's happening
with the kids throwing the ball so much
from seven-on-seven s and junior high in
high school to more password and
offenses in in high school and then
College the air ray
aids in the spread offense is the Audia
you have a lot of talented passers
everywhere when we do an elite 11 camp
and some say let's call it Dallas we'll
have 75 kids that throw a better night
in high school no kid 75
I always address the campers and go you
don't realize if you're at this camp
you're better than I was at this stage
of our career and they are every single
one of them I tell that story because
yes all these guys they're the projected
late round picks or free agents there's
some tremendous value there I'll give
you the one that we do in the in the
Solan science piece is Kyle Allen
started at Texas A&M their thing went
upside down transferred to Houston won
the job in Houston and then major
decides they want a running quarterback
so they go to the zone read game and
here you're Pro dropout guy kind of
stuck in the backup spot he has a
decision whether to enter the draft
which is too soon or transfer again or
sit on the bench and it's really easy
for somebody out there to say oh he
should have done that there was no good
decision so he comes out in the draft
he's very talented he's got a great mind
he's super tough highly competitive I
think he's the guy if I'm taking a guy
in the sixth round set if I'm Mike
Holmgren who always took a guy in the
sixth or seventh yeah as a high ceiling
project I'm taking Kyle and we had
Jordan Palmer here last week he was
telling us that you know he's the third
guy of his of his mentoring with Allen
and Arnold and he said that along with
you know Josh Allen saying that the
kid's been phenomenal on this on the
whiteboard the grease board he's
phenomenal he was singing Jordan I
coached mentally 11 we have a deep
history with him by the way how cool is
what Jordans doing with these guys I
know it was a suicide note but it's just
so awesome to see him take off it was
great seeing him here and having him
here but you mentioned one last thing
for year John is that the the number
that that Josh Allen hit that's right
the best garri
it's scare who did he beat I mean you
know everybody Ivies ever tested so they
give me somebody who even say it's so
like as a comparison he beat even
brandon weeden who pitched for the
Yankees right so that was he was calm
mind I believe you check us on that who
bravely their brain a weiner
I know that I don't mean it's not to hit
anything that might be perceived as
low-hanging fruit but his name you know
doesn't not great problems whereas arms
you're asking just on pure arm strength
yes when you combine that with release
time which is his 0.38 release time is
that's Aaron Rodgers desk
I mean it's you're combining Aaron
Rodgers with a much stronger arm in
accuracy wise he was we had a
competition to hit a crossbar 30 yards
away and he from 35 yards away and he
was the only one who did 1-shot Josh
Allen that's the biggest strike against
him has been his accuracy heat anything
credit he's far as let me ask you a
question just for people out there his
completion percentage the appropriate
number for accuracy I'm guessing no it
is not it's not it's such a misleading
statistic so many other variables that
go into it it's a knee accuracy is
location do you throw the ball where
you're looking or where you need to
throw it now I'm not saying he does all
the time I'm not saying he's super
accurate but please at some point in
this football world can we stop using
completion percentages as an accuracy
metric it's an offensive system metric
yeah it's a processing metric I will say
that high completion percentage equals
high processing because you get the ball
quicker to the right guy more often yeah
but let's stop putting in the buckets
the same completion percentage
percentage accuracy I I've never
understood it
Josh Allen throws the ball where he's
looking at a rate that made my jaw drop
you know in our testing his accuracy his
quick release the velocity on the ball
when you start adding up all of those
factors you're talking about the
difference of 2 to 6 inches on a pass
that's a that's a quick out that's a
huge difference for a DB running 20
miles an hour do we have 20 seconds sure
the sole part is interesting Josh Hollan
2 because I went in skeptical I'd
watched all the film right I'd watched
all the film with Josh Holland and and
there is definitely cause for concern
when you watch the film but then you
start hearing a story a little bit you
start going to know the kid
imagine B cents being said no to buy 998
colleges sinneth ow
and letters he grew up in fire ba then
went to read Li then went to live he's
always heard as no and yet his internal
voices yes and of the great guys that I
know and then I felt that I played
against the NFL that were Hall of Fame
teammates in mind the most important
voice is the internal voice and his
internal voice is really strong this
soul that's all this soul and when you
look at quarterback guys I've analyzed
like drew like Drew Brees and Ben
Roethlisberger and you stack up this
class against those future
hall-of-famers
it's amazing how they are out of the box
ready I think that that leadership in
that system fit is gonna be critical hey
look you know I only know what I see you
know I'm not an eye on the sky tape guy
I leave that to the may ox and you know
and the use of the world Trent but
having covered now fifteen combines I've
never seen anybody drop back hit his
back foot on a seven yard line and throw
it a perfect spiral in the air and drop
it in a bucket on the opposing twenty
four as I saw Josh Allen I've never
owned a few eyes do at the combine this
year I was like oh I almost cursed on
the air right and I did testing when I
saw during the type late against Brett
Favre two times here sometimes three
right that's the gray sorry I plating I
saw no way the two greatest sermons I've
ever seen been rocks actually great
players too it feels when you watch him
throw when you watch him move when you
just the energy his body produces feels
like far feels like Elway when you're on
the field Wow
soul and science on the NFL Network
check it out on Good Morning football
total access across all digital
platforms that debuted on Wednesday do
you want to take a guess at what your
career completion percentage was not
very good
thank you guys I tried very hard never
to talk about my stats my guess is if D
oh god there's some bad years 57 56 it's
it's price is right you've gone over
you've gone all rules it's fifty five
and a half percent but nobody makes fun
of sophomore now
initials should be int not TD Stokely
should have dropped all those balls see
you guys this is a lot of fun Congrats
on now hooking up now hey we're part of
the family that's right could you part
of the NFL Network later what's old is
new again check out again NFL Network's
Solon science at John Brenkus under
Sanders huh okay underscore and at dill
furs dimes on twitter we're back with
more the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience